welcome to weapon crafting and loadout
weapon crafting allows you to dream up
unique classes with a custom arsenal
weapons and there are billions of
combinations seriously guys we counted
it'll make your head explode every load
up contains two weapons so keep crafting
to find combinations that suits your
prefer playstyles design weapons to
dominate every situation every man and
game-mode in designing weapons is easy
start by picking a chassis which
determines the type of projectiles your
weapon fires then just customize it with
parts you can say we have a few to
choose from
okay so let's slow that down a little
parts fall into different categories
like triggers barrels scopes and
magazines all of which help define how
the weapons behave some chassis like
launchers have even more categories that
affect how the rockets fly and detonate
customizing with parts really starts to
give a weapon personality grab a pulse
chat then throw on a spooly trigger
high-capacity magazine and a Gatling
beer
we'll chain with you but it gets even
better after customizing the chassis of
parts you pick the payload payloads are
awesome the payload determines what sort
of effect your weapons projectile has
their payloads that electrocute
burn he'll do straight-up damage and
even increase teammates movement speed
strength there are tons of badass
combinations
remember that pulse can add a Tesla
payload and let it rip
it's blue balls for everyone now let's
try a beam chassis add a shock absorbing
stock add a long range scope smash it
barrel spooling triggers and some liquid
coolant now slap on a pyro payload and
we're good to go
let's switch to a laser-guided
rebounding pyro payload
try a sludge shuttle Pinta barrel
missile launches use a turbo sticky
manual quad question give that yes build
what you want and place your way and
that ladies and gentlemen is weapon
crafting what will you create